on the next episode of better call saul
you ever feel like you're being followed
who's here to see saul goodman
you're the guy right
i'm just getting warmed up
after the last episode of better call
saul it feels more like it might be a
fool's errand to speculate on what's
going to happen in the rest of this
final season but that's exactly what i'm
going to do hey guys pete here today
i've got a quick video to talk about the
episode 4 teaser the promo photos and
other stuff that's out there to get the
old speculative juices flowing about the
six seasons upcoming episode if any of
that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is your chance to leave i'm keeping
this one shorter because i'm working on
a separate nacho video that i want to
get out normally in these previews i
like to talk about some of the big
questions that i saw come up in the
comments of my recap and since those
were mostly about nacho i'll be touching
on them in the other video and during
the live stream on thursday night i
still wanted to talk about what's
happening in the rest of the story
though because i'm thinking we're gonna
be shifting gears and what i was saying
about speculation at the beginning i'm
not saying you couldn't have figured out
what was gonna happen in the last
episode i'm just wondering how much
we're willing to accept i know i was
looking at those promo photos with the
cousins and hector out in the desert and
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
and nacho's execution is just not the
first thing that comes to mind to get
into it though this is the official
synopsis for season 6 episode 4 which is
titled hit and run despite assurances
from the cartel gus takes extreme
measures to protect himself against
looming threats kim and jimmy enlist the
help of a local pro to put on a show for
cliff maine howard seeks outside counsel
gus going to extreme measures makes
sense of course the cartel would tell
him that he has nothing to worry about
as far as alvarez is concerned but he
knows that lalo salamanca lives in the
teaser we see him with the bulletproof
vest on he's watching his home he set up
surveillance we see this shot of the
monitors we've seen in the past and i
guess the trick for him is not to let
the truth of what he's actually afraid
of get out speaking of lalo it's been
two entire episodes since he's appeared
on screen he went looking for proof of
gus's disloyalty to the cartel and it
did also make sense for his story to
recede into the background while they
wrap things up with nachos he doesn't
appear in this teaser either and we
still don't know when the footage of him
looking dapper is gonna pop up it could
be this week it could be the next
as i mentioned in last week's video
peter gould bringing up the calls he
made investigating the werner situation
does make me think he might be headed to
germany but there's nothing additional
here to add to that kim and jimmy
enlisting the help of a local pro felt
like a play on words to me we'd seen
this shot of howard's car pulling up at
the crossroads motel it pops up in this
teaser again and i took this to mean
that we'd be seeing more hijinks with
prostitutes there's even the potential
to bring back wendy from breaking bad
who we know has a history of working out
of this location in episode three kim
and jimmy decided to steal howard's car
and it looks like we'll see that play
out that probably has something to do
with the title hit and run that could be
a play on words as well he could
proposition a prostitute and then leave
hit and run or something unforeseen
could happen when they have his car in
this teaser you also see that shot of
what looks like howard running across
the parking lot and under closer
inspection it doesn't really look like
patrick fabian this would line up with
impersonating him and your first thought
is if jimmy would do this himself he did
a fairly good job of copying howard's
look in the past he still might even
have that suit but i wonder if they
might not employ someone else just in
case because of the risks involved the
only character related to saul and
breaking bad that we've been waiting to
see come back is patrick cubie bill burr
doesn't look exactly like patrick fabian
but it is something to keep in mind
because i do think we'll see the
character come back in season six if the
actor was available
the teaser opens with kim driving she
has the floral print shirt on she
appears to be alone and you see that
she's taking notice of her rear-view
mirror in that we see the same car that
appeared outside the kettleman's tax
services trailer at the end of episode
2. the going theory was that this was
related to howard most likely a pi that
he hired but now we have to start to
consider that it might be somebody else
it cuts to the scene that we saw in the
official trailer where kim is asking
jimmy if he ever feels like someone's
following him and then the teaser ends
with her confronting the person in this
car saying are you following me we can
see the driver in profile but his head
is turned and it's out of focus and it
does sort of make that idea that it was
the same pi that chuck hired seem a
little less likely it doesn't really
look like that guy but for me it's kind
of hard to say it looks like anybody at
the same time
in the episode description it says that
howard seeks outside counsel and there's
a shot of him in someone's office saying
i'm just getting warmed up it could be
davis and main it looks similar to some
of the shots we've seen there but if
this is literally related to him looking
for new council another firm could be
entering the picture to get back to this
driver if that's not related to howard
and it's not related to the salamancas
then who is it ada erickson might be
looking into jimmy and we'll come back
to that in a second but to me it doesn't
seem likely that they would be going to
these lengths while they're still
waiting to get an answer from him if
he's gonna cooperate or not so that only
really leaves gus we see that he's
paranoid we see that he's taking extra
precautions mike had said that they're
watching to make sure he doesn't show up
mike knows that if he does make it back
into the us he might try to contact
jimmy and kim so i think there's a real
possibility there as i mentioned i can't
make out anything from this image he's a
pretty non-descript looking guy
i have seen some people say that they
think that this is one of gus's guys one
of the guys who was watching the germans
at the compound that might turn out to
be the case but a lot of people were
also convinced that this was the same
person that we saw in the gym and that
was the same pi that was in chuck's
house when he was waiting for jimmy to
break in
one other thing about cliff maine when
she's being followed the first time
she's wearing that floral print shirt
and in one of the new promo photos she's
wearing that sitting at a table talking
to cliff so it does look like things are
moving forward there when she's talking
to the driver she's wearing a jacket and
a blue shirt something that looks more
normal for her so i imagine that this
will build up over some time that shirt
looks like the same one she's wearing in
this shot from the official trailer we
haven't seen yet where she's at this
cafe she was talking to someone else
because of the cup of coffee that's
there and i imagine we'll find out who
she's meeting maybe this is related to
whoever's following her and in those
promo photos there is a shot of mike
where he's in a cafe so there might be a
meeting in the future between these two
characters which would be pretty amazing
overall would this be a big deal not
really mike does know about her and she
knows there's a third party that
protected jimmy when he was ambushed in
the desert it could make her wonder what
else is going on there but there's
nothing that suggests that gus and jimmy
ever came in contact in the breaking bad
timeline and the only other shot we see
with mike is of him standing inside
gus's house saying he needs guys in
close which is probably related to
taking care of gus's house in the
surveillance one other thing to mention
about ray seahorn she's actually the
director of this episode and this is her
first one so it will be interesting to
see what she does behind the camera
and jimmy is the last thing to talk
about in the teaser you see the scene
again where he comes into the nail salon
and there's a lot of potential new
clients waiting the character spooge
from breaking bad makes his return
looking a lot better before the meth
grabbed a hold of him based on how kim
presented the options when bringing up
working with the da to help them with
lalo i expect jimmy to choose friend of
the cartel over rat the things we see in
this teaser seem to show what happens
after he makes the decision you see bill
oakley telling him it's just wrong you
see the woman at the window that he
bribes with the beanie babies shut him
down it looks like someone might have
walked past him whenever he was eating
outside so everyone around the
courthouse on the d.a side are against
him and then on the other side you have
spooked talking about how he's
salamanca's guy and all these new
criminal clients showing up because they
want him to represent them he's becoming
more like saul each day at least on the
surface and they were supposed to go
looking for an office so we might see
that happen in this episode with this
high volume of new clients heading his
way his office in the strip mall may be
coming soon one last thing from episode
3 before i wrap this up i took a closer
look at the post-it notes on the back of
the painting and you can see that each
row is a different step in the plan the
first one is the country club and then
the kettleman's with the last note there
saying jay stengel which was the irs
agent that she called what i thought was
most interesting is how many steps they
have laid out this plan looks elaborate
i still tend to think that they know
that howard will be on to the fact that
jimmy is behind all of this and they'll
use that to their advantage but we
haven't seen anything in their planning
that backs that up yet i'm curious to
see how things change in the fourth
episode and i think that's a good place
to leave things let me know in the
comments what you think what you're
hoping to see in this next episode and
join us for the live stream at 9 00 pm
eastern time on thursday if you want to
talk more about nacho please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon